yeah you're right the raiders may have
saved their season with america win over
the jets last sunday
but there's no time to rest with just
four games remaining on the schedule and
right now vegas is on the outside of the
playoff picture
looking in the raiders opened the
three-game home stand with a showdown
with indianapolis and this game could be
key in the afc wild card playoff race
where the raiders currently
one game behind the colts in the
standings basically what this means is a
win
or loss is essentially worth double
should the raiders pull off the wind
they could
swap spots with the colts in the
standings but if they lose
indy could put some distance between
them and the raiders so as you can
imagine there's a huge sense of urgency
heading into this one for the silver and
black
but as head coach john gruden explains
it's the nfl
there's always a sense of urgency i
think everybody needs to have a sense of
urgency
you know in the nfl or you get your
block knocked off we have to
you know we got to play better in all
phases we got to coach better we got to
be ready
there's a lot of chips on the table now
the colts come in at 8-4 and they're led
by veteran quarterback phillip rivers
who will be making his record 29th start
against the raiders
obviously the previous 28 coming as a
charger
and get this rivers also has the most
wins
touchdown passes and passing yards ever
against the silver and black the raiders
defense will no doubt have their hands
full
with the 39-year-old qb brian